High-performance chips are needed to build
our future: whether it’s for artificial
intelligence or driverless cars.
The key to producing advanced chips is by
generating Extreme Ultraviolet light.
EUV light is revolutionary because it has
a much shorter wavelength compared to visible
light.
This allows EUV light to create extremely
small structures on chips - circuitry that’s
10,000 times thinner than a strand of a human
hair!
The more structures that are packed onto a
chip, the more powerful the chip becomes.
The thing is - EUV light does NOT occur naturally
here on Earth - it’s only found in outer
space.
So, how do you generate EUV light on earth?
That’s where a powerful laser comes into
play.
A TRUMPF laser from Germany.
No, it has nothing to do with the former U.S.
president.
This high-powered laser strikes tiny droplets
of the metal tin in a vacuum chamber as they
shoot past.
We’re talking about striking 50,000 droplets
of tin in just one second!
The giant laser takes two shots at each droplet.
The first flattens the tin.
The second, bigger pulse vaporizes the tin,
creating a plasma that generates the prized
EUV light upon impact, at the desired wavelength
of 13.5 nanometers.
Light is projected through a blueprint of
the pattern that will be printed.
In a previous video, I explained how mirrors
made by the German company, ZEISS, focus the
pattern onto the silicon wafer, which has
already been coated with a light-sensitive
chemical.
The wafer is eventually split into little
pieces of microchips.
No other laser on the market can hit 50,000
droplets per second at precisely the right
moment.
Not a moment too soon or too late - otherwise,
the impact will not flatten the tin droplet.
So TRUMPF’s light beam must be shaped in
a very specific way.
Each laser pulse consists of a small, compact
group of light particles hurled at the tin
droplets in a tight bunch.
The plasma that is generated is extremely
hot.
With a temperature of 220,000 degrees Celsius
(or 396,000 degrees Fahrenheit) - which is
30 to 40 times hotter than the surface of
the sun.
The TRUMPF laser is used in the Dutch firm
ASML’s huge machines that perform the crucial
step in the chipmaking process: of printing
tiny patterns - circuitry - on silicon wafers.
ASML is the only company that is currently
capable of building the world’s most advanced
system needed to print chips: its EUV lithography
system.
It’s less advanced machines, Deep UV lithography
systems, can still print quality chips - just
not the most sophisticated kind.
Think of it this way: if somebody were to
write their name with a highlighter in smaller
and smaller writing, in ever smaller writing,
you would eventually need a different pen
to write even smaller.
EUV machines are like a finer pen.
If you own a relatively new smartphone or
smartwatch, you’ve likely benefitted from
EUV lithography technology.
So far, China has NOT been able to get its
hands on these sophisticated machines.
When President Trump was in office, he pressed
the Dutch government not to sell the most
advanced machines to China.
The Biden administration has continued putting
pressure on ASML amid the ongoing chip war
with China.
Washington’s sanctions in October ban U.S.
citizens, permanent residents, and green card
holders from supporting the development or
production of advanced chips at certain factories
in China - which could affect hundreds of
people working for Chinese semiconductor companies.
And perhaps - it could force them to choose
between their citizenship or their job.
As a result, ASML sent out a memo in October
instructing its U.S. employees to stop servicing
Chinese customers.
The memo says they “are prohibited from
providing certain services to advanced fabs
in China.”
until further notice.
A fab refers to a chip manufacturing plant.
ASML has several locations in China for research
and development, manufacturing, and training.
However, at present, it does NOT sell its
most advanced EUV systems that use the TRUMPF
lasers to China.
So, a tightly connected group of European
companies rule the technological world, in
many ways.
The Dutch company ASML is the only company
that manufactures advanced machines to build
the circuitry for high-end chips.
It relies on TRUMPF lasers to generate EUV
light to pattern the finest lines on microchips.
And mirrors from the German company ZEISS
collect and focus the EUV light.
I’ve done videos on all three companies
which I’ll link to in my description.
Other chipmakers then use their EUV systems
to manufacture their own microchips: Intel,
Samsung, and TSMC.
Taiwan Semiconductor Manufacturing Company
makes nearly ALL of the world’s most advanced
chips.
TSMC currently produces 5-nanometer chips
and is striving for next-generation, 3-nanometer
ones.
So, when we talk about the future of tech,
TRUMPF, ZEISS, and ASML are critical pieces
of a puzzle that together are shaping the
world of tomorrow.
It would be impossible to build sophisticated
chip-making machines without brilliant engineers.
If you’d like to improve your science, math,
and engineering skills, Brilliant is a website
and app filled with interactive puzzles like
these.
In this Scientific Thinking course, you have
to figure out what the light intensity will
be after light passes through all five filters.
I know my viewers also really love Brilliant’s
Computer Science Fundamentals course - such
as this course on neural networks.
I used Brilliant myself, and especially enjoy
their Logic puzzles.
It’s made me a better thinker and problem
solver.
There’s something for everyone on Brilliant
- whether you’re a student or already working
and wish to brush up on what you already know.
They’ve got a whole host of interactive
math courses - which will help you see numbers
in a new light.
Brilliant is free for you to try out if you
head to the custom link in my description:
brilliant.org/newsthink.
And the first 200 people who use my link to
sign up will get 20% off Brilliant’s annual
Premium subscription, which gives you unlimited
access to all of their course offerings.
Thanks for watching.
For Newsthink, I’m Cindy Pom.